Hey what's going on is Bill Bird.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday June 12 2017.
What's going on.
Why you and I know what you're thinking.
Yeah you probably saying you me it's time for the Monday morning podcast.
Bill it's so late.
What the fuck.
It's like the sweet one here.
You're never late.
Keith I had your show up in your wife's psych.
Where were you.
We were waiting.
Well it's all cold now
you know.
You want to look at her the way Vince McMann looked at that guy in the sports
show and go oh oh fucking slap a piece of paper out of her hand but you can't
because all your relatives are there watch.
So then he got to sit there and make excuses.
The street like down the street was busted.
So it's just blinking red or blinking yellow so it was real slow and there was
water coming out of the sewers.
And some guy I could believe is some guy in a hang glider square that kind of
got hand God.
He he got blown off course and he landed right right on the side of the
supermarket.
Yeah.
Hit the side of it.
He went down in the boat why can't you just admit you were late because you
don't care about me.
It's not that I care about you.
It's just I just don't give a shit about this.
And I thought maybe if I showed up a little later then it'd be less minutes I'd
have to spend it this way.
You don't like by reality.
Yes.
No I'm kidding
or I'm safe.
God forbid any my relatives listen to this.
I like all my relatives.
I got lucky.
I came from.
I came from a cool family and I married into a cool family.
You know what I mean.
So there you go.
Now I might just covering my bases.
Nobody knows why can't I get the fucking internet here.
I don't know why because I spend 9 million.
I mean I'm like this.
Do you know I said I still have cable I have a dish whatever and I get all the
packages and I know at this point you have these cord cutters.
They just cut the cord and they're they saying fuck network TV.
Fuck 60 Minutes fuck all of that shit.
I guess it's all just going to end up on the computer and just every TV show is
gonna have an app or every network is gonna have an app within the app will be
all the shows.
I'm sure that already exists because I know there's HBO hot take or online or
streaming now.
Whatever the fuck it's called Summer Slam Showtime Summer Slam whatever the fuck
they're calling it.
So I'm old school.
When I am old school is not because I'm down to earth and it's because I do not
want to waste one second of my fucking life trying to figure out how the new
shit works all right.
That's the reason.
I've always bought cars and I drive them for a decade.
I just keep changing the fucking oil.
That's what I do.
The only reason why I went from the Prius to the JAG is just because my daughter
was coming.
And I was just like I better buy a cool car before she gets here or I'm gonna be
fucked.
And I never bought myself a cool car.
Because I don't know.
I've always been a frugal son of a bitch you know.
I didn't want that stupid fuck you know when I was an idiot drive down the
street with your whole fucking coolest car and everybody turn around looking at
you I like blending in the background you know.
Leave me alone.
Dive Bar dive bar.
Night not VIP now down there at the fuckin sushi restaurant where all the
fucking cons hang out with the cameras you know
whatever that fucking show is.
So anyways you know I had I had like a really bad cab driver back from L.A..
I take cabs.
Because I'm not downloading that fucking app on my phone.
And then you track me and see what the fuck I am.
Those Uber cuts all right.
Fuck them.
So.
Yeah I just take the taxi so I get in a cab.
And we're drive and it goes how do you want to go I go let's take the fucking
highways right.
It's the middle of the day here so you know I was peek out the windows would
come into land to see what the floral fizzy looks like.
And
so whatever we get on the goddamn thing.
I know the guy's not the H villain I'm like Buddy there's two of us here.
We are the world we're safe and we're thinking locally and acting globally
right.
This is Greenpeace here.
We have two people in a car.
We get to use the diamond lane and he's like oh da da da da the fuck.
He didn't have easy pass they whatever it is my cousin we don't have any goes
oil costs money and his accent costs money.
Q What is your fucking job is driving people around you asshole if you had that
thing you could get people to and from where they're going.
And you could you could pick up more people right.
You could make more money.
So I'm in the back you know big Hollywood phony getting all grumpy trial look at
look at look at Bill Oh look at him.
He's getting in a taxi cab.
He didn't forget where he came from.
Two seconds later I'm fucking bitching out this fucking poor old bastard
in my own passive aggressive way.
Just mumble in the back seat out of fucking out of the fucking thing.
That's what the fuck you mean.
This is on me right.
He should have said that as you pulled up or whatever right.
So then he just had no instincts.
You know we gotta get off our exit you know on to another fucking highway.
So there's the long line that all these shitheads weighed in and then there's
Tory Ray Ray Liotta lying right fuck you pay me going in through the kitchen
people work 9:00 to 5:00.
That was fish hooks right.
We didn't ask anything we want and we just we just took it.
And then when it was all said and done Yeah busted join out right.
You take that fuck you go round everybody like you're still going straight in
the last seconds you put on your right hand directional you get in somebody's
beep say yeah.
Who gives a shit.
Now you are.
All right.
There was a basic skills that a cab driver should have and he gets in to the
fuckin soccer mom line and I was just like this guy is the worst and I was just
like you know what is an old man.
He drives a cab.
OK.
Who gives a fuck.
So then I just said you know what.
So and he goes which way do you want me to go.
Which highway I go does it even matter at this point.
It's like you're gonna sit in the longest.
I didn't say this pioneer sit in the longest line.
You don't have the fucking HIV thing.
I mean.
You want to just pull over get some lunch.
Oh fuck begonia.
So anyways we get up to that my house.
He goes ape and I say credit card.
So he takes my credit card and he does the whole thing reach it through the
little fucking divider window there and then he hits no tip.
And I go to why you had no tip because he goes.
No I don't know that.
Thing he goes I deserve to be punished.
That's what he said.
I said Jesus Christ.
I'm not taking it to that level.
I was upset.
Half an hour.
I'm gonna fuckin tip you.
He goes No I don't deserve a blah blah blah.
I got off the phone.
It just made me sad.
Don't ever say that.
So I gave him twenty bucks.
Cash.
And he's all fucking me and I gotta get you change and change.
Win.
Is this how you do it.
Maybe that's his scam.
He doesn't have the thing and then in the end he fucking just puts his head down
and goes I don't deserve a tip.
And then a fuckin softie goes No.
Yes you do.
And then he gets twenty dollar tip even though he's stunk of what he was doing
and he still doesn't have to pay for the thing.
I think you know what I think I got.
I think I got scammed
I think I fell for it I think I bought it I bought a
you know a VCR and I opened it up and it's just a brick in the box.
Remember that one that was the old scam back in the 80s.
Hey kid you want a VCR.
Fifty bucks.
Fuckin Hannity and you've run away with the box.
You open it up.
There was a brilliant.
Brilliant brilliant fucking scare you know because even if they asked to open up
the box you know what's in there.
So all you got to do is they got to open it.
You just grab the brick before they do and you smash them over the head.
Then you take everything in his wallet sort of fail safe.
You know unless the guy's bigger than you.
Then as he goes to open his you call cops cops cops and you grab the box and you
get the fuck out of.
I don't know I'm talking about so anyways I had a great weekend.
I went up to the
I went up to Montreal Morrill with Sir Paul Versace and Andrew feminists and we
did the Olympic theater on my birthday Saturday night.
You probably wanted Hey Bill why did why would you do stand up on your birthday.
It's because I wanted to go to the formula one formula one race on June 11th and
when I booked it I wasn't thinking June 10th is my birthday.
I just saw June 11th and that's not an important day to me.
You know.
How dumb I am it didn't dawn on me that my birthday was the fucking day before.
So anyways I go up there.
And.
I go out when Andrew brought me up he goes keep a go for the birthday boy and he
brought me out in the crowd sang me happy birthday was awesome.
He had a fun show.
I get off stage and I walk down to the greenroom and some people from just for
laughs were there and they got me this this unbelievable cured meat from some
place with bread and they had all like the what's that kid's movie
you know with the cast talk what is that.
Is
it called cars.
I don't know.
I don't know I just.
I'm new to the kid game whatever so they add those all up there like I was a
five year old and then my lady sent me up a bottle of Johnnie Walker Blue which
funny because I was trying to be Billy no fund and I was telling her how great I
felt not drinking to get eight hours sleep talking on a birthday and she goes
hey you ought to have a couple tonight you have a couple tonight.
I was like Why do you always do this to me.
I'm trying to do the right thing.
We're trying to go to bed early and you always like Bill you're not an alcoholic
stop being so dramatic you know.
And then I realized oh it's because she got me the Johnny Walker Blue so I
called her up and that she you know we had a good laugh about that.
So I had a little shot of that before I did the second show.
And then the second show at the end of that.
Versace demo was brought out a cake with candles on it and shit and everyone was
singing happy birthday again so fourteen hundred seater I had twenty eight
hundred people.
Most people didn't like my act towards the end sing me Happy Birthday was one of
the best birthdays I've ever had.
So I'm an asshole.
I go to blow out the candles and I go I gotta make a wish I got to make a wish.
I'm in Montreal I go I wish for a Bruins Stanley Cup championship next year
they're all like.
That.
What was funny though was their reaction made me laugh when I blew out part of
the candles without the rest of them so I guess we're not winning next year but
I really want to thank everybody that came out I had such a fucking great time
both shows and that really is one of the great cities
that I've ever been to.
I love that place.
I wish I had more time to spend there but you know I kind of flew up and I was
just tired from that whole week of running around running my yap promoting this
show so I just sort of went into the fetal position before the show I didn't get
to walk around to see anything.
Then I did the two shows and then I went right back to bed
went right to bed and got eight hours sleep and then woke up and went to my
first Formula One race which I have to tell you lived up to the hype.
I don't even know where to begin.
As far as like going out to just see seeing this event that I don't even know
what a year and a half ago I I sort of knew the sport existed.
I mean I knew about it but I wasn't you know doing all this shit.
Yeah I've.
Been watching every single race.
So now to finally show up you know with that going on was like
I don't know how to explain it like the cars fumes just seen the cars alone was
like seen a celebrity to me like oh that's a Ferrari.
That's that's the fucking that's the Mercedes team.
Ah there's the fuchsia the force India team you know.
It was.
It was just an incredible experience we get there we you know we park and you
take a little boat over.
And
I know it was crazy you know Doug the guy does all the wrap up shit you know the
interviews and everything before and after well bucks and he came out to the
show he was telling us she got to come down to the pit area whatever the fuck
they call it the.
I forget what the fuck they call it we had these sick ass passes and we had just
under a luminosity level seats you know every time you think you're in the best
place she could watch and you find out there's another more air conditioned area
with even older manicured looking dudes with the younger hotter looking chicks
every time you think you're at the feet of yet the final level of Dante's
Inferno there's another fucking level it's incredible you know there was a hope
there was one other level above where the hell we were at and that's where the
guys look like you knows what Celine Dion's husband used to look like you know
that guy and he was a bald dude he basically looked like Rob Reiner but he was
the fucking shape shift shifter like lizard level you know one of those guys
that always dressed is all in white like he's a bald do but you even like this
the shit he had left on this side you like that's like a fucking thousand dollar
haircut his beard was like perfectly manicured you don't I mean those guys those
guys he was like their whole wardrobe is like linen and they think yeah they
walk around like a Christ clothes.
They're always on the French Riviera no he's in a fucking yard they got private
jets and then there's always some mirror cat look and chicks sit next to him
that's like fuck and like you know 21 22 and you're like Oh my God
did you pull up in your fucking world cup sailboat you know go into a town and
just walk up to these broke people just you know genetic you know they hit the
lottery genetics and they had this beautiful girl and you just took her away you
know the open toed fuckin sandals
I remember that guy Celine Dion's husband I just remember he not only was he Bob
but his head was perfectly tanned so it didn't even look bad and then he just
had this angelic white hair on this side same thing with like the his beard
it was a different kind of white you know like that you know like those fancy
fuckin pants you can get with it's just a hint of another color in there I don't
know what was in there but you can see why so Celine was just so in love that
she was punching herself in the fucking chest every night couldn't get way to
get back.
I mean if that's what is fucking hair and then side of his head and his beard
look can you imagine this guy's pubes must adhere to like a.
Perfectly tanned junk you know what this fucking angelic winged pubes I can't
even imagine that that yeah we didn't get to that level we got to the level
where was a bunch of people like just fucking real race fans we got to the level
where we had a canopy and I still got a fuckin sunburn that's how what I am you
know cause the sun wasn't on my head but it hit my fuckin chest so get off I can
read and but I want to thank everybody at the F1 race everyone was so fucking
cool.
So long story short
I'm gonna make it funny man I had such a good time so we're sitting like if you
watch a replay of the race when right when they come out of the pit you know to
rejoin the race right where they hit the acceleration you know they've got to
drive like fucking two and a half miles an hour and then they get to this point
where they can fucking take off.
Right right where they take off was where we were sitting and we could see turn
1 and then turn 2 and
it's a whole other game trying to watch the race.
When you're there if you don't have like I mean I wish I bought like a radio so
I could have figured out what the fuck was going on because I didn't know what
happened to Vettel.
I didn't know that the Red Bull guy you know.
Who was it.
Max Max Maximilian there Max for a stamp and right he clipped the front of his
car.
I had no idea what was going on.
I know he paid it really early.
I was like What the fuck.
And all of a sudden he went from second place to like 15th or last in the race.
So I kind of knew but I had no I had no idea what happened.
I didn't know that that fuckin what's his face there.
KIMMI Reagan and I didn't know that he had problems with his brakes.
We had no fucking idea no idea
and it was so fucking loud yet ear plugs in and the guy's talking over but it's
just so goddamn loud
I'm jumping all over this story.
We took a little boat over.
We parked in the garage and then you get this little boat takes you over there.
And then we'll hook this up.
Down in the hole fucking whatever the fuck they call it because of the pee and
we got to look at the garages and all that shit in and we went into the Red Bull
one Jimmy Verde and families got to meet Daniel Ricardo who I famously called
rigger Ricky Reagan or some shit Daniel Ricardo nicest fucking guy ever.
And by the way I want to be in the shape of an F1 driver.
This guy's a fucking ridiculous.
This guy was like I don't know.
He's like five elevens he's got me by an inch.
So he was probably 30 pounds lighter than me.
Fucking amazing.
And he goes yeah we get weighed twice a day right before the Reno during the
race week or whatever it was joking about some fucking broccoli thing that drink
he just drank and how much weight they lose when they're in the car and all that
type of stuff.
I really want to thank Red Bull Racing how for how cool and nice they were and
everything.
They were kind of the exact opposite of this fucking cunt we met from the
Ferrari team.
Granted it was after the race and I thought it was one of the guys was cool.
He was really really nice.
But the first guy we met was a cunt but I think he thought we were being cunts
because I didn't understand.
I knew that Ferrari was having a nightmare of a day but I didn't realize the
level.
I mean I thought was so cool that you know Vettel was able to work his way back
up to the field I was kind of paying attention to him.
I wasn't paying attention to Kimi so when I went down there I didn't know what
to say the guy was like after the race all this Ferrari guys are like smoking
cigarettes too it's fucking hilarious I'll stand up fucking smoked cigarettes
and I just walked up and I was just like
I was just like a man is it OK.
First he gets a picture with you because you want a picture with somebody from
Ferrari you know he's half Sicilian you know.
So the guy Sicily is like yeah yeah and I said hey you know you know good race
today you know you're the guys at least you got power the forced India guys.
And his face just dropped and
I swear to God in his face I understood the entire history and the pressure of
working on Ferrari like he just looked as I can't even.
He didn't say anything and then he just went and I said I was trying to make it
nice again I was I don't need a good race.
When they had a terrific race he probably thought they didn't know this was my
first event so you probably thought I was fucked with a prize probably not a
cunt but you could have seen this guy's face fucking drop it.
I'd say if an actor ever did with this guy's face did in a movie you'd win an
Oscar and now first he's got to stand next to him and first he can read people
better than me.
You know he's half Sicilian half Greek it's fucking over right.
So he feels uncomfortable so I'm trying to make it nice going like all right
this is gonna be a legendary picture or whatever.
And then he goes on and takes a picture and then the fuckin the guy we thought
it was a cunt but probably thought we were a cunt.
He goes No you just missed the legend go by go he goes out Vettel Vettel just
walked by.
We're like really Where'd he go.
He goes I went right now and we believed him.
And then Andrew figured out later that he was just fucking with us.
And then we met somebody else in the fryer team which was really nice.
But
anyways it was a
it was just an amazing fucking time.
I really no.
I don't I don't know how to do it justice it's it was too much to try to
put all into why I guess I started at the fuckin middle and then went back to
the beginning and then I went to the end of the fucking race just know in the
end we were sitting outside of Lewis Hamilton's garage you know after everybody
left and there was all these fans there and they introduced the whole team.
The crowd goes crazy like racing's really big with the fans like they do all
this extra stuff they're great so then they would chant Lewis's name and Lewis
comes out again with another bottle of champagne he sprays it on his team and
then sort of whipped around in our direction and we actually got hit with the
champagne from Lewis Hamilton That's how fucking close we were so I don't know
how to ever top that experience but like I'd like to say again thank you to
everybody who you know Bruce Hales and all those guys from just for laughs for
hooking us up we had a great time and
yeah I don't know what to tell you but I kind of realised just going through
talking to everybody and like the garages and shit just how
it's like Mercedes won't give Red Bull.
They try to buy an engine I guess from Mercedes and they're like Yeah.
Now we're not giving you that basically because Daniel Ricardo's too good of a
fuckin driver we don't need that competition.
However they will sell it to other fuckin teams like I think.
Force India.
They gave them but it's not the same Mercedes engine that they have.
It's really fucking weird like it's like Ah well we'll sell an engine to a team
that we know we can beat.
So we can make the money and help pay for the fucking team.
But we're not going to give it to a good team.
But I don't get how like Red Bull when when what's his face
Vettel was driving for one like fucking three in a row four in a row and nobody
could catch him.
It's like what what what the fuck happened to Red Bulls engine over the last
four years.
You know I don't.
I got my fuckin program here
and I hope I'm not boring you guys to shit.
I'm going to get off this quickly because I know that for me to start talking
about driving for fucking 20 God well at taxing one was a taxi was a nice
mainstream story wasn't it.
Doesn't that count for anything you fucking assholes
know.
If I look up the Mercedes team they've only been around since
2010.
Now I know Mercedes has been racing cars since the 1950s.
I don't get how the Ferrari team's been around since 1950.
Is this like some AMG shit.
I don't have to look up the history of these teams because I found it
fascinating because after a while I was like You know what.
I'm not gonna root for Mercedes and fucking I'm gonna join this sport and then
root for the fucking Yankees or Red Sox.
Mean that's too easy right.
So I kind of like I like Red Bull and I like fucking the.
Force India.
Does because I had a great time when I did that gig in Mumbai.
Comedians over there were fucking hilarious breaking balls and stuff but.
But then I saw the owner of the team or wherever the director is is just some
fuckin white dude.
Force India is there like a fucking Ozzy's looking dude anywhere in there.
That's fucking you know you figure with a name like that.
There's gotta be an Indian dude.
You know
I don't fucking know.
Anyways
what am I talking about.
So I had a great fucking time.
How about that.
I'll leave it at that.
I'll leave it at that and what's his face.
Lewis Hamilton got twenty five fucking points and now he's only what like 12
behind.
He was twenty five behind that was the one exciting thing was watching Vettel
work his way through the field oh and I forgot to say oh the fuckin force India
guys even if you're not into this sport they were going back and forth with one
another.
Right.
The young kid was trying to get through and the Perez guy wouldn't let him throw
would not let him throw right was the other guy's name all Conde wanted to get
through and he wouldn't get him through.
So while they were fighting with each other right in fourth and fifth place
Vettel you know divide and conquer conquer went by both of them in the last
couple of fucking laps and ended up getting into fourth place which was fucking
huge you know and in a way fucked over the Mercedes team you know and I bet they
called him up and say Hey next time you fucking fuchsia cunts want one of our
fucking engines.
All right we give you one of our goddamn engines is the Zagat treat us you block
the goddamn Ferraris we'll get you a faster car out front.
The fuck are we doing here.
I'll give you a fucking Volkswagen engine you do that shit to me again right.
That must have happened somewhere along the line that that had to have happened.
So
is the heist team the American team.
It's so fucking confusing.
I'm sitting here looking at McLaren Honda McLaren and me fucking worked on
Mercedes and Honda used to dominate the sport.
Now this poor bastard every time he goes around the fucking lap dude it's like
he's driving a whoop de.
That thing just shits the fuckin bed every time he he took a fuckin race off one
of one of those guys Fernando Alonso I think he said you know fuck this I wanna
go I'm going to take a race off that's how bad your engines are and I'm going to
go drive the Indy 500 and I believe when he went there is cause engine quit too.
I'm not sure I've been flying all over to help all over the hill all over Dale.
So we went to the race.
I got sunburned.
We saw this stuff do what we were set and we literally saw them pull their cars
and in the end whereas both Mercedes
Hamilton and both us and then Daniel Ricardo we saw em all shake hands.
They walked up the stairs and then we saw them.
You know on the podium we were like to the side you know by the way that fucking
trophy that you get for winning that race.
Jesus Christ that that is one of the worst fucking trophies I've ever seen in my
life.
I think it's just the Toronto the Toronto the Canadian maple leaf.
They just sort of have it elevated with all this stuff but it's just such a
bland
they should make it like gold or something with the red outline of Canada.
You know what I mean.
Red white for Canada and then you put a bunch of gold in there.
You shine it up a little bit.
Jesus Christ candidate all your imagination go into the Stanley Cup.
I was really disappointed with that.
What's funny was the one that Lewis Hamilton got was bad enough.
The one that Daniel Ricardo again I swear to God he's probably using the prop
open some door in his house.
That's how I got to look this thing up.
I really have to.
I got to trash this fuckin thing.
Fuck it.
Come on.
Bill can you believe that cab driver.
I deserve to be punished.
I mean that's the kind of mindset that's I end up driving a fuckin Cabinet's 70
years of age.
He's probably an immigrant.
People are fucking racist and they probably never got an opportunity.
I mean that's another thing.
But that's that's that always can happen to you know.
All right fair enough.
Hey.
Fair enough.
You know who knows.
All right Montreal can I can I can add Bluetooth candidate.
Grand.
Prix.
You know he's enjoying
me talking about this right now is Nashville Predator fans
because the last thing maybe it looks a little bit better it's got some fuckin
it's got a little gold in there
yes it's sitting on like rebar it's just there's just no imagination
I mean could you please put like a red outline around the gold.
You do something the fucking dress this up.
I swear to God if for some fucked up reason I ever won that race I don't know I
got so into this game this this fucking sport and I somehow lost 90 pounds so I
could actually not be you know causing the car to lose and I somehow beat Lewis
Hamilton and Vettel in a non Mercedes non Ferrari engine car if they brought
that trophy out to me you know and I just lost fuckin five pounds.
Pierce and myself as I'm driving around the goddamn track I would I just would
be like yeah you keep that thing you keep it why don't you go back and finish
making that trophy and then I'll accept it.
I'm sure that wouldn't cause any any international incident.
Speaking of an international incident what the fuck the Nashville Predators of
the dreaded.
I lost sight of the puck and blew the whistle.
Welcome Nashville Predator fans.
Welcome.
You guys are now officially been baptized as hockey fans OK.
Up until now you were expansion expansion of.
Hockey fans.
I didn't respect you even with your chance even with Smash ville even though how
far you've come.
I could not fully accept you as fans of the National Hockey League until I saw.
Your team in a Stanley Cup Final score a goal.
But the ref lost sight of the puck and it's waved off.
Now you've earned your stripes.
Now you have a ref that you hate.
You know now you got someone people are going to send letters to and fucking
make death threats and all the other people take it too fucking seriously.
Can you imagine that poor fucking referee.
Listen that Nashville Predator fans somehow figuring out his phone phone number.
Yeah but let me tell you what.
You fucking French mother fucker five kids want to see you again I swear to God
I swear to God.
I swear to God buddy I've got some farming equipment I'll figure out how to
unrest it just to run you over with that after I shoot you in the book and face.
I can't imagine the threats he's getting like I shouldn't even talk about it.
It's probably not even funny.
Unbelievable.
Un fucking believable but I told you guys I fucking told you I picked the
penguins.
I can think I have.
I don't know somewhere around the first round.
I know all these guys look I don't see every staffer.
I didn't see anybody.
That's what you know after Webb wants the Blackhawks got knocked out.
I was just like yeah fuck that's over.
They're going to win.
And then I lost faith with them.
You know what their goaltending towards the end of the auto series.
They prove me wrong.
And then there was that game.
There was that game.
Game for that the predators won.
But that fucking look on Crosby's face when he scored that goal and he didn't
put his hands up.
Like I scored a goal.
He put them out to the side you know gathering his fucking teammates in like
that's 1 like total fucking business look on his face and
congratulations to the penguins you fuck non flights dirty birds you did it
again.
That's Crosby's third that's Malkin stirred.
They now have one more than the fuckin great duo of Mario Lemieux and ya Amir
Jago.
So that's that's really saying something.
They got five they got fucking five.
You know I don't want to start anything but they almost have twice as many as
the fuckin flyers.
Twice as many as the flyers.
Philadelphia.
You're gonna sit there you're gonna take that shit.
You're gonna have to during the off season.
Same way same way I do as a brown fan.
I believe we have six Stanley Cups but we've been around since like Charles
Lindbergh.
So it's different.
Although the penguins have been around for 50 years already.
Just like Dent who would have thought
anyways let's talk about old Billy no fun no fun Billy what's the deal.
No fun Billy.
So after telling you I was going to have no fun you know it was my birthday.
I was in Montreal but even then I didn't go fucking nuts like the last night we
went to my favorite cigar bar up in Montreal.
We went to stockings and
they and a couple of fucking Grey Goose.
Even though I like Belvedere.
Grey Goose is the Pepsi of of
vodka.
You what I mean I always like Coca Cola had the bite you know give you your
fuckin right dear friend you know oh speaking of that.
What about cold lotion cold lotion of the week would have to be they.
The Nationals for predators scored a legal goal and the guy lost the fucking
side of the park.
That is that is that is NHL referee called lotion right there.
That's exactly what the fuck that was.
But yeah.
So I'm not a big grey goose fan.
You know I feel like I'm much like that cab driver that feels like he should be
punished.
I feel like when I'm drinking that I should be feeling the effects of what I'm
doing to my body.
I don't want it watered down.
You got to drink the gas.
You know I like Belvedere.
It's got a little more of a kick to it although I'm not a big Vodka guy.
So I had that I fucking smoked a cigar after the race.
Ten thirty or freckles was in bed.
OK.
So when my alarm went off at five thirty in the morning from my early flight to
get back to my lovely wife and daughter
I was fine.
I was packed I was ready to fucking go.
Everything was fine.
And
but now it's official now back and it's just like
my big thing this year as a 49 year old is eight hours sleep.
I gotta do it I gotta do it because as much as I like going out and partying and
doing all that shit.
Nothing at my age feels better than fucking eight hours sleep so I'm hoping that
I can latch onto this lifestyle and have that be my new fucking drug.
Eight hours sleep
Yeah I gotta do it.
I don't know how to drink recreationally I gotta be honest with you I just don't
know.
I just if I'm doing it I'm fuckin doing it's like I got into F1.
Now look at me I'm spending half the fucking podcast by driving you guys up the
goddamn wall talking about this shit and now you know I went to my first race
I'm going to the one in Austin and then immediately I just go Well that's this
that's two down to down on a 20 if I do two a year in ten years I can fucking go
to all of a you know sometimes that works for me sometimes it doesn't.
You know it works for me as far as like trying to succeed in life because I just
get into something and I fuckin do it.
And next thing you know I crossed the finish line.
But you know when you apply that same sort of philosophy to drinking it it
doesn't work.
It's all about after you have the drink if you have the water afterwards and
you're sort of sober yourself back up again.
I don't know.
I don't think I'm cut out for it.
So I need to take I need I've been needing to take time off for a good fucking
year.
So that's what I'm doing right now.
I'm not saying I'm not going to drink for a fucking year but I'm definitely.
And I will say be funny if I end up in a you know
going to some fuckin meeting
I'll never admit that I'm an alcoholic just go down and listen those fuckin
stories saying the stories the stories are funny but then afterwards he's fuckin
chain smoking don't eat and sad sacks you know I remember when I got busted for
drinking and driving one of the one of the crime rates I had to go to two AA
meetings and to go on Mothers Against Drunk Driving meeting and I was community
service I had to do.
And I remember going to the fucking
fuckin.
AA meeting
Jesus Christ just went you know if you think you have an alcohol problem go to
an AA meeting.
Good lord these fucking people holy shit insane the fucking stories.
Waking up with no teeth get bailed out of jail and fucking walking out with no
shoes right across the street to a liquor store I mean
maybe that's like an extreme version.
I don't fucking know.
Where's Leslie.
Let's read a little bit of advertising here for this week everybody huh.
Huh.
Where the hell is it.
Where is it now.
God somebody's got to correct me on Kryptonite this week
you guys just don't fucking let up do you.
Unreal real Lance we call it I guess the fuckin superhero people they take it so
goddamn seriously.
All right.
I have advertising if this thing ever loads come on loaded up I never even
finished talking about the cable's shit.
I watch.
You know I pay so much fucking money for the Internet and I pay so much fuckin
money for cable.
This shit doesn't work.
You know that the F1 race didn't even record
it started to record.
There was a stat shaking commercial that you can't fast forward past.
Because I wanted to see what would happen at the beginning of the race and then
you know when I went online and just found it.
So maybe that's what I need to do to do that.
I have no idea.
Oh and I think you bring up the fucking Cavaliers.
Holy shit what a game.
What a fucking game.
48 first quarter points eighty six points in the first half.
Un fucking believable.
And it was still it took him halfway through the fourth quarter that's how
little competition there is.
But you know something I think when that little fucking fellow there goes shoots
the three pointers is probably a foot taller than me but he looks like a little
fellow on the NBA court when he fucking pretended to take a shit.
That was one of the most classless things I've ever seen.
He pretends to take a shit and then runs up the court wipes his ass and then
wipes it on the cavalier logo and then afterwards like yeah I was in the moment.
I don't remember what I did.
Get the fuck out of here.
You don't matter what you do.
You know exactly what you did.
You fucking mind shitting on the floor.
I don't know why I got a hit pass.
I get it applies to get open this fucking thing.
All right I'm back.
I'm back.
Went out the kitchen as you saw my dinner salmon
salad with salmon.
Good
canned salmon.
Was a tragedy about salmon is how many salmon get killed a year.
People aren't even appreciated.
You know it's like tuna minus the personality it's just like a fucking choker
with Keith Robinson about that.
We went out to dinners.
You know the fish option one of was just salmon.
And he's just like ag.
Jesus Christ.
It's like salmon is salmon is a fuckin middle act.
You know.
It's a fuckin terminal feature of the fishing world.
All right.
Luke Craig everybody
would be the envy of your friends and get your 100 percent exclusive rate of
exclusive crates at Luke Craig dot com slash BR and enter my code br to save
three dollars off on any new subscription June's Luke Craig theme is alter ego
Luke Craig offers an epic range of pop culture items for less than twenty
dollars a month if you're more of a fanatic fanatical fashionista then try loot
where monthly wearables and accessories with cult classics and your favorite
franchises.
If you want to get fancy get a bigger box with even bigger loot.
I have no idea what I'm talking about right now with Luke Craig D X offer
expires June 19th at 9:00 p.m.
Pacific.
I just don't try and sound like I'm excited about this stuff in dudes Luke rate
you'll find items from Spider-Man Transformers The Hulk and DC Comics one lucky
subscriber will also win a mega crate of seriously epic proportions.
You have until the 19th at 9 pm in case you forgot the fucking two sentences ago
Pacific Time to subscribe and receive that month's crate and then the cutoff
happens.
That said it's over you now as an adult cannot walk around dressed like
Spiderman.
Is that a good thing or a bad thing.
I don't know.
I don't know maybe you dress like Spider-Man and you find some other nerd
dressed like Wonder Woman and the two of you bang.
Ok but how do you get your dick out of that thing.
You gotta take the fucking mask off first right to Spiderman and pull it all the
way down shimmy it over your fuckin fat body go to Lou crate dot com slash burn
it to my coat birth to say three dollars offer any new subscriptions today
but don't be undies me undies look at that fat spider man doo doo doo to me
undies beyond easy should go puke in the can.
I'm not recommending be an anorexic or whatever that other one is where you eat
and then you puke but if your balls are soft you gotta meet your undies just
don't puke down the front of them because that would be disgusting.
Celine Dion's angelic pubic hair.
Of her dead husband.
Sorry.
That one just went off the rails.
Mondays everybody elevate your underwear game to the next level.
Yeah.
What such.
What setting where you eat and then you puke.
Not anorexia.
Believe MC
Oh a tough one on these Mondays.
Da da da believe me.
Doo doo doo doo me on d me on these.
Fucking fuckers.
Yeah.
Believe Mia.
Eminem could write that word bulimia
something Athena.
I ran into arena I can I can't do it.
It's a good thing I did remember it all right.
Minorities elevate your underwear game to the next level with me on this.
You perfected your wardrobe but what about the stuff.
Not everybody gets to see.
No we're not talking about your junk.
We're talking about the cloth that covers it.
If you've been settling for store bought underwear five packs I have something
that will change your life for the better.
My undies.
What's the first thing you put on.
And the last thing you take off.
It's your run to where unless you Matthew McConaughey.
Him it's probably his boots right after he steps out of a fucking Lincoln
Continental thrown junk hanging out.
Where I might make your your most important piece of clothing the best it can be
with beyond is what is beyond this.
Oh just seriously soft feel good undies delivered right to your fucking door.
Beyond these are designed in L.A.
and made from sustainably source micro model model of fabric three times softer
than cotton.
Where did it go.
The copy just went away.
Biondi softer than soft luxury undies come in an ever changing selection of
classic colors bold shapes and adventurous platforms so you can tailor your
undies to your own personal style.
I always think with all the different colors and all this stuff that's what
people like buy like sex swing.
You know what I mean.
They just gotta keep you know make it exciting.
And guess what.
You can save time and money each month with a monthly subscription.
If you're not ready for the subscription that's okay.
You can still say that's because Beyonce's is offering you 20 percent off your
first pair.
Just use our special U.R.L.
mi undies dot com slash burp u r and get 20 percent off your first pair so go
ahead revamp your underwear drawer.
You deserve it once again.
That's me on these dot com sites for me on this dot com slash burn two more.
All right wince wink w i n c whiskey India November Charlie when you have a
great glass of wine.
It enhances the moment
you know what you can't get drunk off a wine.
Jesus Christ that's what they had at the Formula One they had hired Akins and
then they had white wine I drank I was like I don't get all fuckin beer fat so I
drank like two white wines and you know I now understand why so women so many
women a country that do this is impossible to drink that shit and get any sort
of a nice buzz.
You know it's just another thing that's harder for women you know you have no
idea how difficult things are for us somebody write an article
like whether you're reflecting on the day or with someone you love when you have
a great glass of wine it enhances the moment.
Wink understands this.
It's why they started they're going to give you access to exceptional wines from
around the world so you can have more of those moments.
You know what I like a fucking borrow.
If you don't know shit about wine go to wink and get a burro get one that's a
little fruity.
That's the one I like I don't like those acidic ones.
That's a nice one and then there's one that's sort of off the same vine begins
with an end.
I can't remember Newbury Street in Napoli.
I don't fucking know.
Just go to try try wink dot.com.
TR Y W ANC scum.
Take a brief palette profile quiz and wiggle room recommend distinct and
interesting wines.
Actually customize to your palate to be shipped directly to your door.
Every month is a great way to learn about wine by the way you know because it's
a very intimidating thing.
I found that Borrello and I've stuck with that ever since then I haven't dared
fuck with anything French or anything I would do this if I wasn't gonna be
boring Billy here.
Billy no fund.
None of your time is wasted fitting into run to the store on your way home from
work on your way to an event a gathering no more time spent guessing what you
might like because wink bases the wines they send you on your palate
preferences.
Wink will even introduce you to new rare and custom wines that are available
outside deals.
They got a side deal here that not are not available anywhere else and tell you
the story behind each one.
This you always got look for the side deal.
That's a good side deal.
You know who cares.
They go to some local mom and pop a will use this is a rare one and gives a
little dough Ray may will feature it.
Maybe you get the fucking supermarket someday.
You know that's a good deal and right now.
Wink is offering listeners twenty dollars off for your first order.
When you go to try and welcome such br they'll cover the costs of shipping.
That's tri wink spelled T R Y W I N C dot com slash birdie at twenty dollars off
your first order now plus complimentary shipping tri wink dot com slash br.
They ought to have that for cigars.
Wink why don't you do that.
Change it to stink.
All right.
Stamps dot com everybody.
Last one I swear to God stamps save you time and money which you can use to grow
your business for the hassle of the post office and mail everything from
postcards to am loved to packages domestic or international.
Great.
You stamp account.
What the fuck would a mail slot mean international.
Wouldn't want a terrorist create your stamp stamps account minutes online with
no equipment to lease and no long term commitment stamps dot com brings all the
services of the US Postal Service right to your fingertips by imprint.
Official U.S. postage for any letter any package any class mail using your own
computer and printer stamps dot com makes it easy they'll send you a digital
scale automatically calculates the exact postage stamps dot com will even help
you decide the best class of mail based on your needs.
I just don't feel like my needs are being fulfilled.
Sit down bitch that's what stamp comp says and then he satisfies her No need to
lease an expensive postage meter.
We already said that I use stamps dot com any time I'm sending out my posters
then I want to sell after my shows I'm a moron if I can figure it out so can
you.
Right now you too can enjoy the stands dot com service with the special offer
that includes a four week trial plus postage and a digital scale without long
term commitments go to stamps dot com click on the microphones top of the home
page and type in bar that stamps dot com enter bar right.
So the Cavs are playing tonight.
Oh my God.
Oh my God dude.
Can you imagine if they fucking win this one.
Then they going back to Cleveland.
This is how quickly it can turn around.
This is how fast it can fucking turn around.
It would be amazing.
I am not.
I even enjoyed a fucking game in a long time like that.
I was at a bar of course.
Who's kidding who I haven't met Billy no fun I've been Billy less fun today and
by start Billy no fun.
It's just the Cavaliers have to do what they did the other night.
Again tonight.
You know.
And then again and then again.
But each game I think would be less.
And then you know do you realize that at the Cavaliers come back and do this
they'd be the first NBA team to ever do it.
And then secondly Steph Curry taking a shot miming taking a shit wiping his ass.
And does have one of the most classless fuckin things you've ever seen in your
life.
It's like fucking how it goes.
Dad
you know what I mean.
I don't understand.
I don't.
I just.
It just makes me feel old like when he does the no look pass and then he fucking
eat he starts miming like you know he has like binoculars on it he looks at the
crowd doesn't even look at the end of this.
It's like did Magic Johnson ever do that.
I just I for the fucking life of me I will never understand that.
That's like that dance and I told you when I was at the game and there was some
six year old kid dancing which should have been adorable but he had a look on
his face like he wanted to beat the shit out of me.
Societies don't understand what's going on with people
just a complete lack of class and humility is you know and this is coming from a
drunk.
And even I'm noticing
anyways kryptonite everybody.
Here we go let's do some of these these these letters here.
Hello Bill.
Hello person.
I don't know.
I know you don't give a shit but I refuse to stand by and watch you be an idiot.
But the story of Krypton is the planet.
Last week I was talking about kryptonite.
I go isn't it like fucking natural to his planet.
How can Superman be allergic to kryptonite from his planet.
So this guy says Krypton.
The story of Krypton is the planet exploded from nuclear.
From a nuclear chain reaction that's nice and vague from the family back east
caused by the planet's unceasing unstable radioactive core all right I guess
there was a little more of an explanation.
Kryptonite being pieces of the radioactive planet that somehow reach Earth.
OK well then shouldn't those things also affect the humans that go and get it.
You know what I mean.
I don't understand that.
My phone's fucking ringing.
God damn it I gotta take this
I'll call back.
OK so that's what it is.
All right.
So if the vice somehow got off Earth and I went to Krypton and the Earth
exploded they would then be our Earth.
Tonight and then Superman could sit right next to that radioactive rock.
I know it is some point but like Bill can you just fucking play along.
And you just play.
You know why I'm not playing along because this guy said I can't watch you be an
idiot.
Watch me be an idiot like Kryptonite is an actual thing.
This is like you think I'm an idiot because I can't name all the broads on sex
and the city and this is just so fucking made up buddy.
All right.
Sorry I don't know the origins of kryptonite.
What the what is that got you in life.
Huh.
Other than a girlfriend with a retainer.
In her 30s.
All right sex everybody I see that people should be slower to.
I think that people should be slower to jump into bed friendship and respect go
a long way.
Please have Nia and yourself encourage young people to respect each other more
before sex.
Listen I don't give public service announcements.
I mean I just complain about it.
Look if you want to go on get fucking let go and get laid.
All right.
Use use it.
Use a fucking protection but if you actually are looking for somebody
to have more than that then you know.
I think you know something.
Who I am so emotionally shut down.
I can't even speak on this.
I don't know how I lucked out into being near.
It's just fucking happened all right.
But this book.
I just love that somebody like this actually wrote in.
This is very conservative.
This is really interesting.
I think that people should be slower to jump into bed friendship and respect go
a long way.
Please have me and yourself encourage young peoples to respect each other more
before sex.
Like how many listeners do I have on my podcast that the Catholic Church is now
trying to slip in public service announcements
last week.
Well I.
Why don't I give everybody a southern accent.
Have the really the pope in a southern accent say well after we fucked all those
kids no one's listening to us.
Probiotics everyone.
Hi Bill.
I was just listening to some videos on YouTube on the YouTube channel.
Bill Burr archives.
Not sure how long ago this one was from but you are asking for more information
from anyone on how to get clean probiotics.
And I just want to say look up Kaffir Katie F I R.
Camphor is really a racial slur.
I believe it's a racial slur in some country for a group of people.
Travels so much I forget with its flying I looked it up.
I hope I'm not saying that wrong.
You have to fucking apologize.
Hang on a second.
Clever racial slur.
I spelt it like what they just said.
Oh and my internet doesn't work.
Why won't you fucking work Now why won't you work.
Yeah that ad had an
O that's K A F F I R the word Kaffir is the term used in South Southern Africa
to refer to a black person.
All right see that.
I knew I wanted some sad show on how people treat each other so I must be saying
that wrong.
I'm going to say Kiefer Sutherland.
Kiefer.
You can buy the grains and you just add them to your organic milk milk and then
two days later.
Approximately you have Keifer yogurt.
Much better than the store bought ones because they get pasteurized and hence
you lose a lot of the bacteria.
OK.
Cheers fuckface have a good one.
All right.
But then what about the milk.
Where do we get the milk get the milk from an organic cow.
What I just lay off the booze.
I just do that.
Would that be easier.
All right lady needing advice don't want to go to a male friend's wedding.
Oh this is great.
I can give you advice on this.
My girlfriend's ex was gross lady needing advice don't want to go to male
friends wedding my girlfriend's ex was gross.
I don't care.
Okay.
Hi Bill.
I'm a 23 year old guy.
What the fuck is this.
I think.
The lady needing advice somehow got cut off.
So this is a different one.
My girlfriend's ex was gross.
Always the lady needing advice don't want to go to a male friend's wedding.
I will get to the bottom of that by Thursday.
All right.
Hi Bill.
I am a 23 year old guy and I recently moved in with my 23 year old girlfriend.
Everything was going awesome until one drunken night.
She starts to tell me what her ex-boyfriend was like
OK.
She explains that when she was 20 she dated this guy who will call Joe who is 11
years older than her which already fucks with my head.
So being insecure the next day I decided to look them up online and he's
disgusting.
He's fat with an unkempt beard and really short and a pudgy face.
I just can't wrap my head around the fact that my girl being so hot young bang
this slob of a man picturing the two the two together doing what we do now is
really messed up messing me up to the point we stop having sex a week ago.
I just can't get it out of my head.
I mean at one point that disgusting mess really turned around gross Am I just
being an asshole to I break up with her.
Honestly I just don't look at her the same way anymore.
I can handle her vast sexual history buff before me but not with that mess.
It's really screwing me.
Thanks and go fuck yourself.
All right.
Here's one of these things that if you were a woman they would be like well you
have to honor that.
You have to know.
No means no.
If you don't like this then you should honor that that's what you're feeling and
your partner should if they really love you should understand this and wait
until you're able to perform again.
But that's not how it works with guys.
You would be judged for being so fucking superficial and blah blah blah blah so
fucking superficial writing the amount of young whores that I saw with these old
fucking guys at that F1 race.
You know.
I don't know what you do to be honest with you but I mean this is what I would
do in the future I wouldn't Google people she used to fuck.
That's probably a bad thing but I'm thinking you're only twenty three years old.
How did you know.
So she used to fuck this troll probably under a bridge.
Yeah that's kind of gross.
Probably it's some fucking one of those short but fat dicks you know.
Peeking out of his pubes.
It's so disgusting.
I would talk to her about it.
I would just say listen
you know I was insecure that you.
That you were with an older man and was you know not confident about what I was
doing with you in bed.
And my curiosity got the best of me and I googled that guy dude.
For all you know you got the wrong guy.
By the way might be someone with the same name who knows
you know I don't know but it's I don't know.
In a week's time you can't get past that.
I mean she's probably looking at you like you're a champion.
DEC I was a 34 year old fat disgusting fuck and you're twenty three imagining
and shape right.
I don't know.
I don't think it's weird that you looked at the guy and then obviously you just
pictured and fucking your girlfriend that's disgusting I don't think that's
weird at all.
Women would say it is because they always defend each other for some reason yet
they fucking go at each other like alley cats when we're not around.
I don't know.
I guess it's like some female like union you know they act like union men or not
unionized which just every man from fuck itself.
Although I am sticking up for you.
So who knows.
Yeah I would know.
I think I talked to about just say you know do you think this makes me
superficial she's gonna be like yes I can't believe you charge me like that I
just
I don't judge people on looks I know you judge them on their wallets.
If he has a nice personality and a private jet you know I don't mind a little
extra weight.
You know what was going on with that guy.
Maybe that federal was taken out to a nice restaurant every night so he could
keep her and that's how he got fat.
I don't know if have a giant head to those big fucking butcher block heads all
right.
Jealousy issues
jealousy issues Dear Billy rosy cheeks.
First up I'm a huge fan.
Keep up all the great work anyway.
Me and my girlfriend of four years just moved to France.
She is French and all her family is here.
We lived in Australia and planned to go back to Australia in 11 months.
Sorry had to get that your know.
Our relationship is very serious.
We never laugh.
Not kidding.
I love this girl so much.
They plan on popping the question soon.
We were at a local bar last night.
I'm not lingual enough to talk.
Well at a bar yet.
So when we go out it's hard to follow what's being said but I still have a
pretty good time.
After I had a few drinks with her and her friends this guy my girlfriend works
with sits with us while it's just me and her about 3 a.m.
and I immediately felt bad.
I'd never met this dude but when he sat down my girlfriend didn't look at me for
10 minutes and was 100 percent focusing focused on him leaning in laughing etc
while I sat on my phone or looking up at the sports.
Yeah dude that's not good.
That's not good.
Repeat that is not good.
I couldn't understand what they were talking about and there wasn't a way I
could be a part of it.
I didn't like the way this guy was looking at me as well.
Twice during the time after 10 minutes she shrugged only puts her hand on my
knee and after five more minutes I tell her we should leave.
I say goodbye to her friends and walk outside.
I smoke a cigarette and wait a bit longer.
Go back inside and she is still at the bar with this guy paying her bill.
Same on Beyonce's before.
When we leave to walk home I mean I'm immediately cold with her.
You should have been she fucking embarrassed you.
You absolutely should have been.
You do what you wouldn't do that to her would you.
I was pretty drunk so I expressed my dislike for this situation in an overly
angry and and impatient manner.
Yeah you should away t was so this one of these things where you were right and
then you were drunk so then you became wrong.
By the way you said it 20 minutes into a 30 minute walk home.
She was tearing up pretty bad and told me she was talking about me and other
harmless shit.
Bull fuckin shit
she was talking about her dog and her dog was sitting next to it at some point
she will look at his face she would have done that.
She's full of shit.
This is my gut anyways.
Well the feeling stayed between us when we woke up this morning.
I don't get to socialize much here and I really like this bar where everybody
goes to.
But this felt particularly bad.
My girlfriend acts more natural in this country so this is awesome for her to be
with her fellow countrymen but we've never in four years had a conflict where
jealousy is an issue.
Have you ever had an issue where your girls talking to a dude and it crosses a
line.
Absolutely.
And I was drunk and I said something
yeah.
And that didn't end well.
Can I deal with this without affecting the relationship or how my girl acts
socially.
Deep down she is an absolute sweetheart and really sensitive so it's a bit
delicate.
Also there's a part of me that says maybe it's all in my head Anyways hope you
can help Bill any advice be great love to the birth family.
Go fuck yourself.
All right.
Well there's so many factors.
Yeah you could be jealous.
But you know if it was actually 10 minutes and she didn't look at you and then I
said I'll meet you outside and she said she's still in there talking to him
about what a fucking great guy you are.
At some point to you your gut doesn't lie.
Unless your head's FUCKED UP.
ALL RIGHT.
IF IT'S COME ANY from your gut.
If it's not coming from between your ears and it's all this fearful thoughts
that she had and you need to quiet that down.
But if it's coming from your gut you judge guts just saying this just isn't
fuckin right.
And who's kidding who.
The French have different ideas about that type of shit.
Where you know I'm not saying everybody over there but they did that they're the
whole fucking having a image mistress.
You know.
It's not looked down upon.
It seems sort of accepted as the resentment builds.
I don't fucking know but
I just don't
that whole situation is bad and I actually think her reaching over and pat you
on the fucking leg to keep to keep you at bay there.
I even think that that makes it that made it even worse.
Now haven't said all that you should have waited till the next morning
or at least when you walked back and I just say listen I'm a little drunk right
now so I don't want to have a big conversation but I would like to talk to you
about what just went down with that guy.
Like that ever works with a woman.
No you.
Yeah.
Knowing you can argue about you know
I don't know what to do.
Who knows.
Who knows what the fuck that was.
I would be like All right.
So is she only
the way she is because she's in my country and she doesn't know anybody.
But this is out.
This is how she really is.
Is this just a cultural thing that she used to fuck this guy and she's psyched
to see him and this is going to be her little fucking fling on the side when we
get married.
I would know what the fuck they think
but I would try to regroup and just be like you know.
I find it hard to believe that if I was at a bar and I started speaking a
language with another woman that you didn't know and I didn't even look at you
for 10 minutes and then gave you a pandering pat on the fucking leg and then
tried and then I went outside for a smoke and I came back and you was still in
there talking this person this woman.
If I was talking I'm saying if I was talking to this woman that I was somehow be
able to convince you that I was talking about you the whole time.
I don't know what to tell you sir other than the practice upon your French
practice up when you're French and do it without her knowing
get that Rosetta Stone should get you a French game in order and learn all their
Minaj a trois fuckin was Watts ass over there.
Gross.
Jiro is something like that.
You gotta know what the fuck he's saying.
To your girlfriend so I don't know.
I don't want to tell you.
My gut says that that was fucked up.
I could just tell you that I'm not trying to drive you away from this woman but
that's that seemed fucked up.
If that was coming from your gut sir.
God damn it I would go with it.
All right.
That's it.
That's the podcast.
If you enjoy this podcast and you'd like to donate without a caution you a dime.
Just go to Bill dot com.
Click on the podcast page and there's an Amazon link there.
Anytime you want to buy something off Amazon just go to my Web page.
Click on the link.
I get credit for Drive and traffic to the website doesn't cost you any more
money.
Whatever you were gonna buy.
They kicked me a little fuckin cash or whatever fuckin tidbits whatever they
call those those people money.
Coin thinks
Brexit.
I don't know it's called.
That's it.
That's what you can do and if you don't want to do that I completely understand.
I don't give a shit if you keep listening to you cheap fuck all right.
That said go fuck yourselves.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.
Let's go Cavs.
Congratulations penguins.
My condolences to Nashville fans.
Thank you to everybody.
The Formula One race and I can't wait to watch the next race.
I don't even know where the hell is that but I will be watching and I actually
finally watch the Italian Gramp Moto GP by the way trying to tape those fucking
races is so difficult every time I go to click it's the fuckin Moto 3 Moto 2
it's the fuckin time trial I always gonna click every single fucking one of a
before I finally get to the race.
I got to see the Italian when these motherfuckers were going like 220 miles an
hour on motorcycles and I finally figured out the KM thing every 50 miles an
hour is 80 kilometers.
So you just keep adding 80 every 50 so 50 100 miles an hour when 50 to 80 miles
an hour is 80 160 240.
What the fuck would that be 320 roughly.
All right there you go.
Here's a little metric system for you.
Go fuck yourselves I'll see you on Thursday.